j'enfile mon gilet pare-balles
pour les ambulanciers de karkhiv c'est
devenu la routine
sortir sous les bombes russe pour
soigner les blessés
c'est clair que c'est dangereux de
travailler sur la ligne de fond mais si
ce n'est pas nous alors qui le fera
direction salti fca un quartier du nord
de kharkiv pilonné nuitées jour par
l'artillerie de la lumière poutine
les habitants sont sous le choc
plusieurs missiles grad viennent de
frapper le secteur
ne pleure pas ne pleure pas
l'un d'eux a éventré cet immeuble
résidentiel
toutes les vitres ont été soufflées par
l'explosion
et les policiers craignent une deuxième
salve
dégagé dispersez vous dispersez vous
de l'autre côté de la rue c'est un
centre commercial qui a été touchée
caserne écoles ou hôpitaux la tuerie
russe ne fait pas dans le détail
depuis le 24 février les pompiers de
karkhiv sont au semis des jours
et le pire c'est qu'ils bombardent
souvent plusieurs fois le même point
nous avons eu des victimes dans nos
rangs
[Musique]
ce supermarché une filiale locale du
groupe français auchan aurait été
partiellement gagné par l'incendié
pour évacuer les victimes
il faudra plusieurs ambulances
ça va aller nous sommes ukrainiens
dans cette si de river un blessé par les
éclats de verre
les russes c'est vraiment
des criminels de guerre
arrivé aux urgences la vieille dame est
encore sous le choc
milan de l'attak un mort et 14 blessés
[Musique]
retour sur le lieu de la frappe où les
résidents font le ménage
secoué mais stoïque
c'est rien ça m'est égal ce fils d'anna
professeur d'ukrainiens à la retraite
nous invite à constater les dégâts
le missile a explosé au niveau de la
cage d'escalier mais l'ondé de choc n'en
est pas resté là
c'était tout ce que je possédais
à celui ci a survécu ça me fait
tellement plaisir
les assiettes sont tombés elles sont
toutes cassées
c'était tellement joli ici
et à la tombée du soir les bombardements
reprennent sur le quartier
d'après ses résidents environ 80% des
habitants ont fui ce quartier du nord de
khar qu'yves ceux qui sont encore là ont
appris à vivre sous les bombes ils
disent que kharkiv et leur ville et
qu'ils y resteront